初めまして荒川ですよろしくお願いしますここでですね15分という時間を頂いてお
話しさせていただきます
あの皆さんまずこうして座ってこれされている僕自身っていうのを見たら先ず一つ疑問
に思うと思います
なんだこのチャラ男後
実際出てきてしかもバリバリの関西弁で何なんだこいつはとしかも紹介してもらっても
小説家とがゴミキレがよくわかんないと
実際会おうと思います6自身をなにしろよく分かりませんでどんな仕事をしているかと
言うとですねご紹介されたみたいに
まあ今7冊の本を出して小説家作家の仕事をさせていただいているのと後です
ねゴミ拾いという活動で全世界15万人以上集めて5月の3日
ごみの日に一斉にゴミ拾いをするという活動をさせていただいています
まだ一方で全国の中学校高校で300校以上の学校で講演会をさせていただいたりだと
か
また総理公邸ですね今の内閣総理大臣安倍晋三氏の奥様の安倍昭恵さんと一緒に首相
公邸
体で一緒にテレビ番組をやらせてもらってまして
そちらの mc をやらせていただいたいまた一方で実は大阪に2店舗の飲食店の経営
をしているというまあよくわかんない人間ですよ本当に
でそのよくわかんない人間がなぜこうしてできたのかという話を今からさせて
いただこうと思います
お供の始まりですね皆様とおそらく今在校生がいらっしゃると思います
2006/11/8僕が上智大学3年生の時ですね
自分のことを嫌いだったんですよ
おそらく皆さんの中にも自分のことを嫌いなんです私自分を嫌いす死んだほうがまし
です
俺本当に家てる価値ないよねって
yuko もしかしたらいるかもしれません
僕自身も本当にそうで夢がなかったんですね
醍醐卒業してもやることやりたいことも見つからなかったし目標見つからない
適当に卒業して適当に就職して適当に結構せひろみ死んでいく
っていうことが良いと思えなかったんですね心の奥底でずーっと自分を変えたいと思っ
て大学生活を過ごしてたんですけど
同時に一つの言葉が心に浮かんでました
何かしたいけど何すればいいかわからない
中学生高校生大学生全国に行くとみんないます
何かしたいという何をすればいいかわからない僕レシーブ本当にそうでずーっと自分
変えた自分会で何かしたいとずっと言ってましたそれを大学3年生のある日6一向に
兄貴がいるんですよ
兄貴にこう言われました
お前なにかしたい何かしたいですね口ばかりやんけ
ほんまに変わりたかったなぁ
なんでもいいからね黄銅製よ
って言われましてその pot ばがすごく響いて初めて何かをしようと大学3年生の
時に思ってそして僕はに言いましたよ仕上がったじゃあな俺
毎朝6時から新宿駅でゴミ拾いするって言った言葉に対して兄が公開しました
なんで
わけわからんですよねなんで自分回だけで新宿で5匹でなのって話なんですけど僕
サークルもやってなかったし部活もやった方趣味は寝ることだし範囲もギリギリ
そんな人間が今更二十歳で頑張りますーっても頑張れないんでさっき言って
なんにもできなかったですその後に気づきました俺本当に何もできない
思ったと同時に
でも
ゴミ拾いがあったできるかもなとその時思いまし
その時にできることはゴミ拾いしかないならとりあえずゴミヒロやろうと思ってそうし
て選んだ場所が朝6時の新宿駅東口
まず朝6時かというと事業とかがあったのでで新宿駅って言うとやっぱり卒中の見やり
ててあそこ汚いんですよね皆さんご存知通り
通してやるのはいけないところやろうと思ってそうして毎朝6時から新宿駅で込
おいている挑戦が自分を変えたいという思いで始まりました
それが2006年11月様から話だんですけど
まあいざやってみたらですね本当に僕バカだったんで
背中に一緒に掃除してくれる人募集という看板を背負ったんですね
なんででしょうかねぇ
モテると思ってたんですね
いやもうて編ってどうでしょでもあの時の本当に果たしては彼だったんで
あのときあそこでゴミ拾ってたらキャバ嬢とかやるとか家出中の女の子ばっかりオップ
そこで俺が各5位日和ってる姿に急でなるかなと思ったんですけどまぁなるわけない
ですよねまぁそこにあった現実というのはホスト
ホームレス酔っ払いそのまま
過去その筋の強いと子ばっかりでしてまーす5嫌がらせを待ってまして
目の前でゴミ捨てられて顔に唾がれて蹴られて殴られてこれ本当の話です
集めた分よばっさーて町散らかされてい
それで頭からジュースかけられて挙句の果てにはカラスの死骸ので釣られて
ここまで気に食わないんだ俺のこと
逆にあなたすごいですてみたいよね
たことが本当にあってされた僕はに来言われたんですよ前どうせあっても気づかんから
時間だけは決めて絶対その違いありところで僕は2期2ヶ月
行ってしまったんです
そのせいで1階ザとりあえずつけようと思ってそれでも頑張っ
ましたでもその間も結局変換に巻き込まれたりとかいろんなことがあって何度もゲーム
s なってくるしてそうになって
でもそんなある日ある人が手伝ってくれたんですね
ホームレスのおじさんでした
半分穴でてました
なんで判決って思ったんですけどねそれでも初めてできた判決のホームですがすごく
そこが嬉しくて初めての中な嬉しく次の日も次も新宿に足が向かっていくうちにまた
一人とホームレスのおじさんが増えて
そしてそうしていくうちに気付けばどんどんどんどん1か月っていう目標を達成できて
それでもずーっとせていくと1か月半経った時には目の前にゴミを線なホストの
お兄さんが僕のところにゴミ持ってきてくれたり
そうしてある時は怖いおじさんがね缶コーヒー買ってくれるようなそんな変化が
どんどんどんどん入ってきて
サラリーものおじさんが湯茶いつもありがとうご苦労さまという言葉をかけてくれて
そうしていくうちに新宿に行くのがどんどんどんどん
楽しみに変わってる自分がいてい
そうして2006年12月年末ですね
gomi 拾い始めて3ヶ月ある出来事が僕に起きました
新聞に出たんですね
朝日新聞が取り上げてくれたんですけど
このような記事でした
この1名に僕が乗ってました新宿東口20歳の清掃
ここに母校ゴキ映っています掃除をする ana かゆ13
沿えば取材みたいなあったなと自分変えたい派タチアナ会場時代振り付けた上智大学生
です
言ったなとそして朝6時に一人そしてその後にこのように書かれていましたこの記事に
は
ます
世界変えたい
言って a
アホかと
このチヂミって骨でまたは幸いなんですけど喪失がまったうわぁって人がそこから
どんどんどんどん集まっていきまして
5人白い25に2232後順次どんどん増えていって
このシームれた版2子については nhk が活動を特集してくれてテレビラジオに出
まくった結果凄い人が増えてきてはある日なんか2月の8日僕を終えてます北海道が
ありました沖縄から来まー走者からここに来ましてどんどん増えていって
ロシアからこそどっから触れません
この放送は国際放送までてロシアからフル試聴がではロシア人が出来まして
結局人が増えて由布市にみんなどんどん協力的に代わってくれてそうし3か月4か月5
ヶ月半年経ったときに初めて2007年5月の3日
ゴミの日ってことで全国
にゴミ拾いしようってイベントを開催しました
そうしたらその時全国27カ所
444人という仲間が集まって
その時気づいたんですね
初めて自分を好きになれたんです
でもその理由ってのは何だったか
自分を好きになりたいって皆さんいますよく全国の中学校高校に行くと右になります
講演会で出会った生徒さん
自分好きになりたいですでもどうしたらいいかわからない
でもその時の2007年5月のみっかぁ
一つの答えが僕にありました
自分を好きになること
それは
自分を信じること
自信を持つことだったんですね今まで何をしても俺無理無理でピンできやもずリアから
と言ってに入ってる自分なんか不思議はなりませんでした
それでもこのゴミ拾いを通して生えることができた
続けることができたそれが全国に広がっていった
その経験を胸に宿すことができた時大きな壁を目の前にした時に今までなら
あーむりむり止めとかやめとこって下がっていた一歩が
おっちな壁を目の前にしたその瞬間だって己の時できたも
dat ラン耐えれたもん
だから今回もできるって思ったらその一歩がパーンと
前に踏み出すことができな
そこには台数が自分がいた
そうして僕自身は大学を卒業して
2008年5月の3日全国で約50か所
1500人に広がって2009年5月の3日全世界に26石
15534になりそうして2010年5月の3日税世界30か国以上
10万300036人と一
ろざり今では全世界で60カ国
15万人以上という流れに広がっていますそして一方でどんな仕事をしているかという
とその話を
学校で講演してくれませんかっていうお話をいただいて初めて大学4年生の4月に学校
で講演会させてもらってそれを一生懸命やっていくうちにその話面白いですねっていう
ところから本にしませんかという依頼をいただきました
そして一生懸命本を書いていくと君の文章面白げて次の本堂です勝って相手に山3冊4
冊5冊やっていくうちに今の小説家という自分自身がいて
そうして活動を継続していくうちにあれ総理の奥さんから
人からゴミ拾いの活動を聞きました凄く感動しましたというところから一緒につながっ
てもらって今では総理公邸で一緒に番組をやらせてますそしてまた一方でずっと継続し
て活動していく中で貯まったお金で
かつての俺と同じ想い here 今では店長は中国人の元フリーターの子だったりと
か中卒元ニートのパティ
今では50人以上の従業員を抱えて今社長ということもやらせていただきます
程度が今の2006年11月11月8日から2015年5月31日の僕自身のこれまで
の歩みなんですけど
長々と話をしたのも理由があってそれは何だったかというと
they 国の中学校高校でも同じ話をするんですけど今こうして皆さんがこうして
座られてここで喋ってる荒川祐二っていうのを見たら
最初だけ見たら全戸前世から15万に集めて5分拾ってます7冊の本だして小説帰って
ます
300校以上の学校で講演会してます安倍総理の奥さんと番組あってますラジオ番組を
もっと持って
やってました50人以上の従業員を抱えて社長やってますっていうあらかゆ者聞いたら
あんただからできたんでしょうって
あんた特別でしょうって俺には無理
あんたと私違うからって
思うかも知れませ
でも
自分の話をしたのも理由があって
このたった一言の言葉のために今日があったと思ってくれていいです
それは何だったか
15万人以上集めてゴミを拾うことも7冊の本を出して小説家になった荒川融資も50
人以上10行か書いている社長やったら可愛い子安倍総理の奥さんといいまともには
ラク鮎師も分かっていてほしいことは一つで
西へ
全部の始まりは
2006/11/8
あの時始まった
誰にでもできる
ゴミ拾いだったという事を皆さんに伝えたかったんです
できるかできないかじゃなくて
やるかやらないか
1日で始まったんじゃないです
そして俺は皆さんにゴミ広島賞ってご披露した俺みたいなれますよか勇気ないんですよ
皆さんは皆さんでやりたいことをやったり社長成田へ
カフェを開きたい ca なりたい看護師になりたい色
んな思いがあっていいんですただその時に同時に思ってほしいんです
俺はこうなりたい私はああなりたいっていう理想郷
治療も描いてそれと同時にじゃあその理想の未来のために今
俺に
今
私に
この瞬間何ができるかな
ちっさが一方でいいんです
インターネットで調べるそれに関連する本を読む
人に話を聞いてみる
その小さな一歩がたとえ1メートルでも1センチでも1ミリでも
あゆみせているうちに必ずその1は
1ちろ10期は100基の1000 k って祖父がつながっていきます
その始まりはその道の始まりは
今この瞬間だということを皆さんに6はこの場を借りて伝えたいなと思っ
だからこそ大切なことは
皆さん自身の一歩を踏み出す勇気と
そして
あきらめないか子です
いつか変えたいいつかやりたい
そのいつかっていうのはいつ買っ
本当に
今この瞬間だっていうことを伝えてこれで僕の話終わりにしたいと思いますから本当に
ありがとうございました
第よりも鏡を用意してくれたスタッフのみなさんに感謝します本当にありがとうござい
ます